to understand the blind spot we first  need to understand how images are formed  and perceived light enters the eye  through the transparent cornea and the  lens where it finally forms an image on  the retina it could be formed anywhere  along the retina and then this image is  sent to our brains via the optic nerve  and we perceive the image  along the retina there's a tiny area  through which the optic nerve and the  blood vessels leave the eyeball  in this tiny area where the optic nerve  passes through the surface of the retina  there are no photoreceptors and hence  the images cannot be formed and  perceived this tiny spot is called the  blind spot of the eye here's a simple  test for you close your left eye and  focus on the dot on this image with your  right  slowly get the phone close to your eye  and at some point you will notice that  the plus sign will disappear that's your  blind spot go on do share this video  [Music]